anh
alo cho nó cả bạn
trước hết thì mình muốn cho các bạn xem cái clip này trước đã
Đợi mình tí nhé
và b16i ca nhạc xa giấc mơ đi để ở
những nét hơn
em song có vẻ nó không cho mợ thằng màn hình
thôi Từ Đà la Hàn về được à
sơ đồ án này là làm cái một chàng trai mà làm nghề phục vụ bạn ước mơ Không ghét
sao mẹ nó học nhiều thời gian để dành cho người yêu của mình
đùa này á là làm gì trong web trang web có thể bán hàng nói tin tức trang web cơ
bản thôi Ừ đợi tí cho mình phải ghi lại có vài bạn chắc là mới à
ừ ừ
Ừ
Ok bạn xem video này trước đã mình sẽ tâm sự gọi là
em hâm nóng gì vậy ạ ở hầm nấm không khí đã trước khi bắt tay
vào chiến nha à vi phạm vi một chàng trai mà làm nghề phục
vụ vào giấc mơ không ghét xong cái đã học cần nhiều thời gian để dành cho người yêu của mình không tinh tế kiểu
không kiếm nhi nha anh sẽ biến kiểu con trai Garen này rất về chiều em luôn phải
chịu em yêu một chàng trai mà làm phục vụ hoặc là làm bơ không có đâu có văn
hóa không tốt cái điều gì quan trọng hơn trong việc dạy tiền bạc tiền bạc Sống
thực tế nó không có tiền bạn thì tao không lo được gì cho một mồi thì em phải là còn nhìn kiếm ra tiền rồi sao đâu Lo
cho một mình nhưng mà như một chàng trai mà là phụ là super không Dạ không con mẹ ơi kiu lăng nhăng không nhận thời nhiều
tình cảm cho em nó cái nhục nhã cho thì cố gắng làm những cái việc mà phải luôn rồi Làm sao để đủ kinh tế cho gia đình
cho mẹ phải về tất cả mọi việc nổi thì em không trả lời này đó là mình thường
lâu dài sẽ bị chỉ cho vấn đề vật chất Nó hoàn toàn đã nát luôn là anh shipper thì
như cây Bo nè không ra lại hay nóng tính hay nổi giận tao giờ bắt được thì họ có
thể bộc lộ tiên đứng các tơ nó nhận được mà Nhưng được mình sống Sài Gòn thì mình nói ra không nổ đúng phải từ 15 đổ nước
nó biết tính đến lâu dài tương lai ngủ hiểm hay là không hiện quá mất cái
nhượng gái khác với lại mình tốt để tuần này mày chừng đó hơn nếu bạn đi ăn đi
uống cũng đặt sát đồ này nói em không thấy người ta đó là thôi + tính dối nó
giá thấp người ta có chỗ nào con trai làm phục vụ là tiếp ơi không có thời gian hay gạo trại heo kìa điểm sĩ Bơ thì
mất luôn không quên Tại vì sống này thế nào đã định thì cần Ngô còn nhiều tiền lắm anh ạ Giống như một công việc khác
nữa của Super điện thoại phải tính tộc phải rô nói rồi cô gái mà làm nail hoặc là mất cắp không mình nghĩ thì con gái
làm cái gì không quan trọng yếu là kiếm tiền bằng chính sức lực của mình đó có thể là không đủ chạy chỗ này không làm
mà không đủ tiền thì mình nghĩ là mình gì được cho bạn đó em rồi phải có sự chân thành với nhau chứ nhận gì thì
không quan trọng lắm chẳng thấy công việc nào cũng là công việc chỉ cần mình kiếm ra đồng tiền sạch là được không có trong công việc tính chất là như thế nào
đương ít cũng được Còn không làm cũng được dùng như là em có quan trọng của việc quá đấy ta thật lòng người nơi cùng
vun đắp thì Ok Không có gì chị đây tôi không phải thằng bột rau ạ
Em không biết được là câu chuyện vừa rồi khiến nó các
anh đợi mình đi [âm nhạc]
Ờ không biết là có chuyện vừa rồi khiến các bạn nghĩ gì không Mình thì mới xem
cái bây giờ mới thôi à à à
anh kể cái này thì da mình không đánh đồng rồi nào cả mà Bởi vì a chính mình
luận thì chúng con gái cũng cảm thấy kêu vậy Video là khá là phẫn nộ của
video là các thứ thứ con gái cũng nói Ô thế mình mình
ý mình muốn nói về cái việc là là chúng ta nên
nên bắt đầu công bằng đúng ạ Mình cũng vừa bình luận ở trong cái nhóm nhóm
tên là qua ra vn nhóm thường ai đăng đăng những kẻ bài dịch từ trang diễn đàn
của Lara về thì Sao Paulo Nó diễn đàn nước ngoài được người nước ngoài họ sẽ nghĩ khá nhiều
cái à mà và cậu chủ đề mà đương nhân vẫn nhạy cảm nó chủ đề về giới tính thì mình
vừa ủng hộ 1 cái bài mà kiểu anh hiểu được kêu gọi công bằng cho con
gái và thực ra là nhiều người bình luận ở dưới sẽ bảo ở lại Nữ Quyền à con gái
lại là nạn nhân hả Thế còn con trai thì sao với Vân nói ra thì ờ ờ các bạn đôi khi cũng không hiểu được
khái niệm Nữ Quyền cái nữ quyền nhưng nó là làm kìa ra con là đấu tranh đứng ở
đấu tranh để bảo vệ quyền lợi con gái nhưng mà để với mục tiêu là để công bằng giới tính
trước và mục tiêu để cho con gái đè đầu cưỡi cổ để con gái Kiều ạ
không phải là này không phải làm được không phải là người kia à
à Xong rồi được đối xử kiểu và hơn cả con trai Nữ Quyền khoảng
như thế Nội quyền để công bằng là sự như là hồi trước tôi đọc mấy cái nó bảo là
độc quyền để mà đòi cho con gái được đi học như con trai được tham gia chính trị
con trai Vân Vân được mức lương ai chứ không phải con con gái rồi kia đòi nữ
quyền thế không phải một áo ngực tôi từng xem những video hay vãi chưởng ho
gà ở không phải làm việc nhà với đương nhiên Đúng vì việc là con gái việc nhà không
phải là cứ con gái phải làm Ừ thôi quan điểm tôi với nguy hiểm thế đó Đó là kiểu
bình đẳng thôi Ai có thể chia như nhau việc ở là thứ ba tội khá lời vực nhà tôi
không bạn người mẫu mực không phải một người hoàn hảo thể thế nên là nếu mà Giả sử bạn ấy cũng
không thích làm việc nhà thờ ra về sau tôi nghĩa sẽ thuê giúp việc cũng được Nếu là sự cả hai cũng không thích đâu ạ
Bạn ơi Không cần phải giỏi nấu ăn luôn đấy tội chẳng liên hoan gì cả thì vẫn có
thể thuê người làm những cái từ đấy em còn về việc vun đắp và gia đình là sự
như là nuôi dạy con hay sinh con thì anh nhiều đó là thì cái điều đấy cả hai cùng
phải đành phải chia sẻ lẫn nhau ngoại Vân Vân thế không thuê được ai cả à
ở Đại Thái thì mình mình nghĩ là cái nữa quyền được dùng từ Nữ Quyền lạm dụng lắm
nhiều ông thì dại gái cũng cũng vui theo nhiều ông không hiểu cái từ đấy cũng
ngồi theo xong rồi Chửi nhau to về chủ đề ngày khá ngợi cả nhà mình nghĩ à
mình mình nói vấn đề đấy Mọi người cảm thấy á
cho nên nhìn nhận cái từ nữ quyền làm như thế nào thôi I
hệ thống kê cứ gọi tôi thấy tôi hi vọng Còn mấy ông gọi tôi là anh thì nó hay
hơn em chào anh hiểu như bạn kia à
Ừ ok Nói chung nhà mình tâm sự em một tí nữa trước khi mình
bắt đầu để thử nói qua đây mua nhé mình nói các bạn là mình học liên thông
để mà lấy giấy cái bằng cử nhân đại học rồi không ạ Mình Hồng cực mình
lấy bằng cử nhân công nghệ thông tin để về sau mình có thể xin vào trường đại học vẫn thể dậy được ở trường đại học vì
ít nhất là phải có bằng cử nhân thậm chí là thạc sĩ
cái nhàng Bạn muốn dậy rồi kết hợp với cả chứng chỉ chứng chỉ sư phạm nữa
nhưng mà Bởi vì bởi vì cái việc dạy học ở đại họp nó yêu cầu thêm rất nhiều bằng
cấp như thế thành ra là Ừ tôi không biết mấy ông cậu đang học
lại ở đây có bao nhiêu ông đã học Công Nghệ Thông Tin ở đại học
A2 ở kể cả Cao đẳng nữa có bao nhiêu ạ
Ừ tôi thì cá nhân tôi ở từng học qua chính xác là hai trường và từ trường của
tôi nhưng mà chúng tôi liên kết tính cả bên Cao đẳng nghề nữa thành ra là khai trường về công nghệ thông tin
và tôi đương nhiên là tôi cũng học thêm một khóa khóa học bổ túc và học ở đây
nữa đừng cụm với bún trường cùng với ông tin vào tôi biết bạn bè tôi chia sẻ nữa
từ Đại học Hà Nội Đại học Bách Khoa số ngồi đến cả Học viện Bưu chính Viễn
thông rồi Học viện Kỹ Thuật Mật Mã mình nhiều lắm nhiều
em còn mấy cái chữ mà không chuyên rồi công nghệ không tin nữa còn nhiều nữa tôi có bạn bè các thứ thứ ở Hà Nội ít
nhất là Hà Nội Ừ thì tôi thấy mặt bằng chung ấy ở đó là các thầy đồ rất giỏi lý thuyết
em và nó rất là sai khi mà khi mà cậu
mình đang dạy nghề nói hạn như thế điển hình giống như là thầy Chiều nay
vừa dậy thôi ạ Thầy lý thuyết nói nó lại toàn bộ những cái trên slide nó lý
thuyết rất nhiều cũng cũng không quan tâm có người nghe không trả Đang học bên
thông cách dậy thấy thế Tôi không nói có thầy khác như thế nhưng mà ý thôi à thì
viết nhiều quá bởi vì họ có băng cấp đến thạc sĩ Tiến sĩ mà nhưng hãy ra họ học
quá nhiều nhưng mà chính mình như thế kệ cái thực tiễn của họ về cách họ cốt
cũng như là cách họ để giải quyết bài toán hay là cách Họ giới
thiệu cái vấn đề Cho tôi nghe rõ Cảm thấy cửa làm như thế
này chỉ khiến sinh viên chán hơn là và không và không có hứng thú với ngành này tôi
dùng từ như thế bởi vì chính tôi là người học công nghệ thông tin tôi biết thầy đang nói cái gì mà tôi còn cảm thấy
khó hiểu và nó cứ sai sai nó kiểu rất là mông lung
chứ không phải mỗi thầy chiều nay mà tôi đang nói Cậu hầu nhựa Tôi đã gặp các
thầy cô có thể khá nhiều rồi các thầy cô hơn bị lý thuyết quá
ờ ờ bởi vì có thầy cô ấy không dành thực
hành nên không dám không không dậy được thực hành ấy ạ
nhờ các thầy ta thấy tôi hướng dẫn bài tập tôi còn chẳng hiểu làm những kiểu gì luôn sai vãi chưa ạ
cho nên là có nghĩ là về sau tôi sẽ Tôi
không biết nói mấy ông chưa là tôi à Tôi về sau tôi định quay fshop
để mà dậy Ừ vợ tôi nói vụ đấy chứ nghỉ ngơi chưa đấy Ngủ ngon tôi về sau tôi định quay
Shop FPT Shop anh có anh người tôi về
đây dậy để dạy về à em dậy nhớ mà tôi về
đây dậy thì thường có ai thì lại là theo kiểu là đào tạo khi mà có người và
xin vào thực tập mất rồi chứ không phải là dạy từ đầu nhưng mà các bạn còn đang trên trường đại học ở
Ừ tôi không biết là tôi có về sao có về đại học FPT là dậy không đến đấy thì
chúng ta hỏi Nghe nói do họ cung cấp các thứ thứ ghê lắm nhưng tôi tự tin là cách
tôi dậy nghề hơn nhiều thầy cô bây giờ chú ý tế Nhất là nghiện như tôi đã bảo
là cái cách dạy cách dạy đại học thì lý thuyết cũng không hẳn là sai nhưng mà
với cái ngành nghề này thì phải truyền được cái đam mê cho sinh viên để sinh
viên có thể tự học mà đúng không sinh viên kiểu gì lên đại học lại tự học Thì cái mình cần ở đây không phải truyền tải
kiến thức đâu không phải truyền tải kiến thức thì mình phải đam mê và truyền tải là món sinh viên nó hiểu và nó thích cái
ngành này nó sẽ tự mò Ừ chứ không phải là kiểu mình
truyền tải rất nhiều kiến thức kiểu gì đó chuyện sau các thứ thứ
và sau đó sinh viên chẳng hiểu gì ra sinh viên dễ làm ngành này tỷ lệ bỏ rất
là cao tôi không biết ngành khác như thế nào nhưng một ngày này tôi thấy tim bỏ cao lắm áo kiểu và và mang tiếng là trường nào
cũng đào tạo công nghệ thông tin trường đạm đã công nghệ em tin Kể cả không phải trường chuyên về công nghệ vì cũng là
tạo về công nghệ công ty rồi cùng tỉ lại đi làm vẫn hát ngành này vẫn được cho
ngành hót bởi vì a vẫn thiếu rất nhiều việc làm và đương nhiên có rất nhiều bạn giỏi
nhưng mà rất nhiều Bạn giỏi mà tôi biết lại không học Công Nghệ Thông Tin ở
trường đại học mà tự học tự tìm để Đam Mê Bằng kiểu dạng nhiều cách ví dụ ở đây
tôi khẳng định trong kênh của tôi đang có gai bạn cấp 3 có thể tự tìm hiểu từ nguồn khác không phải chặn trên tự
trường và bạn đầy đam mê ngày công nghệ viên và bạn ấy dẫn khí ở lên đại học học
cho có để cái băng hạn chế của một lên đại học học xong năm thì bỏ vì các thầy
chỉ khiến mình làm như trí hơn Ừ ông quen mấy người như thế Tôi quen
rất nhiều người như thế từ cái Mạnh Tuấn này Việt Thảo này xong rồi tất cả mấy
anh em trong Tru Tiên II có điều bỏ đại học để mà kiểu Em tự học
ờ ờ thế nên là tôi cảm thấy nó cứ bị say quá cái vấn đề này thì nó vẫn là một vấn đề
này cả thầy giáo dục nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy à Nó cứ làm cho mình
áo kiểu tôi cảm thấy nhớ lúc ở Tôi muốn kiểu phân thân ra thì đi dạy nhiều nơi
tối không khẳng định là tôi dậy hai đứa dậy tốt hơn mấy cô đấy nhưng mà tôi tin là cứ truyền cảm hứng tô hơn mấy cô ấy
để cho giữ cho mấy em ấy lại cho tôi tôi không đôi khi là tôi không
cần dậy rồi nhá Bởi tôi nói thật là tôi từng nhà làm à gì nhỉ trợ giảng
13 Quận pháp cho cả lớp tiếng Anh hả nói cơ tôi biết cách để mà khiến cho một bầu
không khí của một cái lớp học nó số động hơn và kiểu kiểu dạng là giáo viên cũng
dậy sẽ hào hứng hơn các thể thơ Bởi vì tôi là học sinh của bạn mà nắng nổ mà
nên là tôi tôi từng được thuê lúc đấy Tối học tiếng Anh sau đó thì bởi vì tôi
kiểu biết làm cho lớp nó không khí rất là ổn Đấy Vì sao tôi được học miễn phí thời gian cho thuê để nó coi để làm trợ
giảng cho cái lớp học này thì ông phải hiểu lại cái cách của tôi khiến lớp học nó
đang tải nhạc anh vui à thậm chí giống như tôi đang học liên thông ở đây này thầy cô đang rất tẩy nhạc và tôi là lớp
chưa Không hiểu sao tự nhiên mình đã xưa rồi tôi cũng khiến đâu cái lớp sôi động
hơn tí các thầy cô dạy cũng sẽ hào hứng và thích dạy hơn cũng như anh A và tội
sẽ hỏi thầy cô để mà tránh việc là thầy cô cứ kiểu nó theo kiểu là cầm cái giấy
đọc Đấy Tôi sẽ hỏi thầy cô và thầy cô sẽ trả lời những cái câu thực tế hơn
Ừ nếu hiểu cho tôi không vẹn thấy câu nhá Tôi sẽ không phải một cái đứa mà kiểu tặng tao biết cái này rồi xong rồi
tao sẽ vặn vẹo thế Cô Bóc mẽ thì cô không nó sẽ đứa mà giúp thì không khí do
học sẽ kiểu tốt hơn nên tôi tự tin là tôi ít nhất rồi Không dậy thay thầy cô
lấy thì tôi có thể làm trợ giảng tốt được cho một cái lớp đấy
Ừ ông kia tự nhiên có đoạn cốt lỗi gì vậy
mà mình từng nói qua về có cái bằng cấp đại học rồi thực ra thì phỏng vấn có hỏi
về vấn đề đấy nhưng mà khi mà các bạn không có gì để khoe họ mới hỏi cái đấy
anh hoặc là người phỏng vấn không biết về công nghệ thông tin chương 1 khi biết cùng em tìm tôi Tôi
bảo tôi còn không cần phải phỏng vấn ơi được vào thẳng luôn rồi vì họ đã biết qua trình độ của mình mà biết mình như
nào rồi Thế là để mà nổi như thế thì tôi không Tôi không khiển mấy ông đều như
không hẳn nổi đâu chẳng qua tôi chia sẻ nhiều những cái tôi từng làm những cái
tuner tới chia sẻ trong nhóm này không ấy chia sẻ ghét pháp này cũng có người biết đến thì tội Long dậy cho mấy ông
những cái mấy ông hoàn toàn làm được những cái như thế mà đúng không cái đấy đó không hẳn là khó tối thường chỉ qua
mấy ông rồi à à Ừ nhưng mà về Bằng cấp thì thì giống như
tôi ở bà là trừ khi các bạn về làm cho nhà nước hoặc là cho mấy cái trường này
nó vẫn yêu cầu bằng cấp không được không cần kể cả bằng tiếng Anh Không Cần
từ trước khi về sau đi làm đấu thầu thôi đấu thầu thì nó vẫn có đồ họa gì đó
nhưng mà lúc đấy các bạn có thể học nên hoang như cậu học buổi tối học cuối tuần
là như tôi học một cái gọi là chó có bởi vì nó gần như điểm Lang ấy người áo
trắng học hỏi từ gì mấy vì có thể cô ấy cứ bắn trang thương rồi cũng chẳng quan
tâm của anh nghe không Nếu không học được gì mấy đâu dự án nhưng mà về cái vụ đấy thì tôi
cũng nói thêm việc tôi tôi ghi ở Kia là thầy cô dạy môn chân thành nó sao nữa
thầy cô dạy môn Công nghệ thông tin thì có vấn đề như thế con tất cả những môn khác rõ là tôi đăng ký hoàng ngành công
nghiệp vi nào ngon những thầy cô dạy không em đi thì rất là chán còn những thầy cô không dậy của mẹ ông tin thì
thực hiện rất là hai tâm huyết lấy cô kém tấn hiếp nhá Đầy tâm huyết ở đây là
tấn viết về Dậy thôi chứ không tâm huyết thực sự là kiểu sinh viên của nghe không có có quan tâm mình nói gì nữa không Âm
Nhạc các thầy cô khác thì liên tục hỏi sinh
viên cầu này có kia Dinh viên trả lời này ví dụ là muốn chính trị-hành môn à đạo đức này thì nhiều môn á thì
có thầy cô dạy rất là hay cô chia sẻ rất nhiều cái mà kiểu mình
cảm thấy là cậu cái đúng rồi Đang về học Còn công nghệ thông tin thì lại khiến nó
tôi cảm thấy à Nếu mà tôi mà chưa học không Em tin mà tôi học cùng thầy cô lấy tôi sẽ nghĩ ở miền Nam
học sai ngành thời sự tôi dậy bỏ của người thông tin với một xong mấy thầy cô
gửi hết đó là đương nhiên mình vẫn ăn cố nói giảm nói tránh tế nhị thôi
Ừ nhưng mà thực ra thì à khi họ cũng họ cũng làm toàn bộ khả năng
của họ rồi chẳng qua là họ kiểu tôi bảo rồi đôi khi mà
khi đôi khi là và họ cái tân của họ không đến mức đấy nghĩa là họ làm tốt
công việc của mình theo kiểu dạng là theo như mọi khi họ đã làm như họ không
quan tâm là việc đang dạy cho ai không không bởi cái mục đích là kiểu hệ sinh
viên tốt lên nghĩ sâu hơn về vấn đề đấy mà chị quan tâm được rồi mình đã làm đủ
trách nhiệm của mình Ê mấy ông hiểu khái niệm làm đủ giống
như kiểu dạng mà bồi bàn đấy có thể ra hỏi ông Mặt lạnh như tiền nữa hai ngọn
gì chứ Xong rồi điền vào chỗ ngồi bưng ra chẳng chào nói gì cả Ừ cái kiểu phục
vụ kẻ dạng hả kiểu lạnh nhạt đi kiểu gì thế à à
Nghe giảng viên giảng viên tôi thấy là giảng viên công nghệ thông tin thì như
là chỉ cần bằng thạc sĩ Công nghệ thông tin này được thì phải hoặc cao bằng cử nhân công nghệ thông tin được kèm 2 bằng
sư phạm và được thì phải a trứng chị sẽ gặp chứng chỉ chứng chỉ dễ học bằng sơ
phạm mới khó
anh hả ờ ờ à mà lãnh cả là thực ra là cái bằng sư
phạm nó cũng nghe tôi nói như nào nhỉ Ừ tôi chưa học ở đại học Sư phạm tổng
vẫn chưa có lấy cái chứng chỉ hay măng có thể gây rối có thể nhận xét cái chân thực nhưng mà bé ông đi học có một cấp
hai người ông so với kiểu đại học mấy ông thấy cái dậy người khác đúng không khi họ chắc chắn ở không cùng một một
nơi mà ra rồi không cùng một lọ nữa rồi tất cả nó họ sẽ Kiểu Học cái kiểu xử
phạt kiểu khác Nhưng mà quan trọng là ở cách cách dạy của họ khác hoàn toàn nữa
nhận ra cũng chẳng biết đánh giá như nào
Ừ đúng rồi thực hành thì em nhắc tay là một chuyện nữa khi nhiều
thầy cô vẫn còn dám không phải dùng thử dám nhưng mà gọi nha Nói Dối
Hoa chắn gió giúp đỡ chém rõ ở những cái kiến thức đấy em chẳng ếch tôi nhiều lúc
ở tôi một bát mẹ cũng cực ai ngờ tôi bảo tôi không muốn tỏ ra mình thằng biết thằng phá tượng như thế thực
sự nó vẫn nhiều cái kiểu các thầy cô truyền đạt sai ở đâu có thầy cô chưa có
kinh nghiệm thực tế lý thuyết thì nằm đấy Cái thiết lắm chỉ nằm ở mức cơ bản cơ
bởi vì đã đi làm gặp ngoài đời thật cả đời đâu để mày hiểu được thực sự nó như
thế nào đúng không ví dụ dỗ cô hôm nay của Thầy Tôi sẽ xóa
nửa cái đoạn đấy nó vẫn chạy chẳng hạn như thế Thầy kiểu cốt đúng kiểu xe hoa
luôn Kiều đi đầy đủ toàn bộ từng bước từng bước đầy đủ nhưng rất Rập khuôn
em à có thầy còn cho xem YouTube và tôi biết hôm trước cũng có thấy vứt cơ cho
lớp tôi là Linh Youtube cho Bảo và lấy xem xong rồi làm bài tập bắt chước như thế ngoài cái video này không nhận lại
được mấy trộm nhìn nhìn được xem tội biết được chất xả nào
thầy đã từng gửi cái video ấy sao rất nhiều rồi
Ừ thôi Bây giờ lại đi hơi xa rồi chúng ta tâm sự thế cho tại với thế thôi các
bạn có ờ ờ Nghe giảng viên vừa đi làm vừa đi Dậy
đúng rồi giảng viên nên vừa làm đi dậy Bởi vì thực ra đi dạy tôi cũng từng đi
dậy và tôi cũng hiểu kìa đi dậy sau một khoảng thời gian ông lâu không Cốt đấy
thì ông kiến thức ông bị mai một đi rồi Vân nhưng mà may mà người thầy của tôi
hồi trước nó bảo tôi gặp người thời đấy vừa truyền được cảm hứng vừa có cái Tâm nhìn ấy Thầy bắt tôi ngồi làm phần mềm
nhà trường đấy để cũng là một phần nào giúp như này giúp nhà trường quản lý
sinh viên các thử tốt hơn chứ không phải bắt làm không công cho trường đó nhé Chỉ vì đơn giản vì mục
đích cả vì sinh viên này nhá thấy không không hại vì trường tôi từ trước này tôi không còn điện vì trường nào đấy vì sinh
viên hết thấy cũng vì sinh viên này mới lại mới yêu cầu tôi như thế và cũng muốn tôi vẫn luôn giữ được cái tay nghề tay
nghề của mình không phải là kẹo lúc mà nghỉ dậy rồi mình sẽ không làm được việc gì nữa thấy có cái tâm như thế có tầm
như hết lúc đầu tôi khá khó chịu ngược Đấy khi mà thấy lúc nào cậu vẫn gì đấy
like Nhưng mà mình kéo mình cài mình đi dạy học nhưng dẫn 15 phần mềm nói thử vẫn có mắng mình giờ sự của bấc gì gió
người phần mềm ở chỗ như đi làm bình thường luôn Nhưng chính mình như thế nên
là mang tiếng là tôi kinh nghiệm thực tế là tôi đi làm vẫn chưa đến một năm khi
mà mới sang công ty mới này nhưng thực tế là tôi làm phần mềm gì chỉ phần mềm
đã hơn 2 năm rồi mà ẩm thực tế Hà Nội bởi đưa vào ứng dụng luôn anh ra tôi vẫn
con chỉ kỹ năng nghề rất tốt
thế hả web medimart đó mấy ông mở VPN lên
cài cái cloudflare 11.1.10 tại này về mở lên
Ừ đúng rồi Thế nên là hồi chiều tôi bảo rồi đó là tiêu chí của thể A cái gì À
đúng rồi Cái tiêu chị à trong tử nghèo các tiêu chí để mà kiểu đánh giá các
thầy cô trường tôi ít nhất đó là không để ở sinh viên chở được
ít nhất là như thế Nghĩa kẹo anh dậy sao chó không phải để chiều sinh
viên đó nhé anh Bởi vì chiều sinh viên Song đến khi nó kết thúc khóa học nó vẫn chửi kiểu
thầy cô chẳng chạy ra cái gì đấy mình mình phải kiểu làm sau sinh viên vì sao không chờ được mình
Ừ tớ làm gì ạ dạy không phải mỗi tròn vai nữa phải đúng là cố gắng để nó học được
thêm cái gì họp nó cảm thấy không phí tiền không phí thời gian ngồi ở đây đấy một điều nghe vậy đơn giản đâu nhưng mà
khó đấy giờ khó
bài hát mình dùng telegram làm gì thế ông lại nghĩ tôi làm gì đó Nghị cảm đúng
không Cho tôi mở lên cho xem qua nhé Đợi tôi mở lên nói cho
ở đại miệng mèo heo Thế có cái gì ở những cả nữa em chả bảo gì nhạy cảm đấy
em về L'Oreal này nói chuyện với anh Mạnh Tuấn đấy chuyện với anh nữa này
chẳng có Cái nhóm gì ở đây nhóm đi Cả mày nữa em à có nhóm gái xinh này của tôi tạo
nếu mà ông nghĩ thấy nhóm nhạc cả nói chị Nhàn gái xinh rồi đấy
thôi không bậy bạ Nhưng mấy ông đâu
thế hả kể chuyện ma Ừ tôi hỷ à em chưa được nghĩ về việc tôi kể chuyện
ma luôn từng kể đấy tuần kể chuyện nhiều nhiều chuyện lắm truyện 18 + đó
Ừ nhưng mà không tôi không hướng đến làm chi mua quyển truyện ma hay kể truyện 18
+ à à à
Ừ thôi bắt đầu đi hơi xa quá rồi Hôm nay mình sẽ đến vào và họ mình mình sẽ đem ô
để mua qua mình thử thuyết trình sau đó thì mình sẽ có 2 ý nghĩa là có hai nhóm
tình nguyện tình nguyện là bảo vệ Tối nay rồi thì mỗi nhóm tầm tầm 15 phút
thôi nhưng có thể hơn có thể hơn đấy và có nhóm nào muốn tình nguyện nữa thì
có nhắn luôn Ở ngay đây để mà nhắn số số nhóm để mà tính mình sẽ cho bảo vệ nha
Ok có nhóm của ông tốt nhé tôi ông ấy chưa nói tình nguyện lâu nhưng tôi sẽ
Anh miễn cưỡng tình nguyện ông ấy Ừ ok
có ai tôi tôi sẽ chữ trình như bình thường đâu nha Nhớ đương nhiên
là tôi sẽ không tự hỏi chúng tôi rồi nghe nó em nghe nói sao ấy
thực phẩm chứa thằng bạn tôi còn bảo là tôi về sau tôi phải đóng kiểu blockers JVevermind có một lúc đó nhiều nhân vật
rồi có quay màn hình nhưng mà không tôi không hướng đến mục tiêu ấy ạ à à
em như lời tôi nói lúc đầu không nên làm hiệu ứng về không ai quan tâm đâu
thế hả em anh em không tin huyện anh em không tình nguyện thì anh bảo ở
cho miễn cưỡng tự nguyện nữa Ừ thôi bắt đầu Nga Thế là xin chào tập thầy cô các bạn đã
đến buổi bảo vệ thế trình của nhóm and ngày hôm nay à em em mà Nguyễn Long là
trưởng nhóm thành viên của em là những bạn đã nghỉ rồi những cục tạ
sau đây nhóm em sẽ thuyết trình về đồ án 1 là trong web bán về laptop laptop của
em cố hướng đến là laptop liên minh ah à à
ở đầu tiên là về lý do chọn đề tài thì bởi vì là bây giờ Thời buổi công nghệ
4.0 rồi nên nên là nhu cầu về thiết bị điện từ đặc
biệt laptop sẽ rất được quan tâm đặc biệt bây giờ dịch dạ các thứ là mọi thứ
đều làm online nên là vững mua laptop thì đã tràn ra sẽ ngày càng phổ biến mà
nhiều và bọn em lại hướng đến là về laptop liên minh chứng là laptop dành
cho giải trí là nhiều hơn nhưng mà cái Laptop Gaming thì vẫn có thể sử dụng để
mà kiểu chạy những tác vụ văn phòng hay là tóc vụ xử yêu cầu Cần xử lý vẫn rất
là mượt nên nên là em thấy nó là một thứ mà kiểu khó thể thiếu trong thời đại này
và à mà quan trọng là Xu hướng bây giờ làm
cái gì Online mua bán online nên thành ra ở cần có một trang web để mà chúng ta
thể lên đấy tham khảo thuận tiện à à
em không nên làm hiệu ứng rất mệt à bên đối tượng người dùng thực ra là cái đối
tượng này tôi hỏi đại tội Hiểu nhầm cái đối tượng Đối tượng tôi đã tưởng tượng Tôi đang bị hiểu nhầm sang đối tượng
khách hàng của tôi ra tôi đối tượng người dùng là khác nó nhà ý tưởng tượng khách hàng của tôi thì đối
tượng khách hàng của bọn em hướng đến thì sẽ là về ví dụ là sinh viên nhân
viên nhân viên văn phòng hoặc là game thủ đôi khiển như em đã nói thì cái laptop
liên minh có thể thao dành cho những người cần tóc vụ cao thì có thể làm
những cái về thiết kế đa phương tiện nhờ cái tô cũng được
A và A và từ đó thì chúng em rút ra được là đối
tượng để mà sử dụng trang web này sẽ có 44 mọi người dùng Chính thứ nhất là
khách vãng lai khách vào để xem mã sản phẩm Số ngồi à Khách hàng đã đăng
ký khách có thể đạt được sản phẩm và nhân viên bán hàng và Quản trị hệ thống
khi thấy bạn lai thì thì sẽ là vào có thể đăng ký Rồi từ đó đăng nhập rồi Xem
toàn bộ sản phẩm tính kiếm a và có thể xem những cái thông tin
những bài bài tin tức ở trên trên trang web
ừ ừ cô gái thấy không kéo sợi làm hiệu ứng
rồi cùng nó có bị lệch khỏi chịu đó
lại là như này khó chịu ở khách có tài khoản thì sẽ có đầy đủ quyền của cách
mạng like nhưng ngoài ra thì sẽ còn xem được thông tin cá nhân đạt được hàng Xem
lịch sử mua hàng và hủy đơn hàng chứ à à
cô nhân viên bán hàng thì sẽ có sẽ có thể quản lý sản phẩm quản lý sản phẩm
đây sẽ là xem thêm sửa không có xóa xăm thuật có quản lý khách hàng cũng xem
thêm sửa khách Hà ờ ờ có thể xem hóa đơn và duyệt duyệt
đơn về tìm kiếm đơn và có thể đăng bài Đặng quản lý bài đăng
ở Quản lý hiển nhiên có toàn quyền của nhân viên Như ngoài ra thì sẽ có quản lý
thêm nhà sản xuất quản lý slides ba lô và quản lý ẩn những cá nhân miếng khác
anh ở đây là sơ đồ thực thể của bọn em sơ đồ thể này con gà Tôi bảo rồi cái hình này nó bị
chìm hai hình thì ra là rất khó trình bày nhưng mà ít ra là hai hình này nó là hai tính
năng độc lập nên hơi ga vẫn thể Trình bày được em thừa mà tôi sẽ thường bởi vì tôi đứng
để nói thì sẽ là có chỉ chuột mấy ông nhìn thấy con chuột rồi thì có thể chỉ vào nó tiện
cho người dùng cái gì đó để chỉ gì dụng là ở đầu tiên à Bọn em sẽ lưu bảo em sẽ
lưu thông tin sản phẩm bao gồm các thứ ở đây đúng không thông tin Sẵn thông tin
sản phẩm rồi thông tin khách hàng rồi Khi mà khách hàng mua hàn thì sẽ thông
qua hàng chọn sẽ thông qua hóa đơn một khách hàng hiện tại cần nhiều hóa đơn và một hóa đơn thì sẽ có nhiều sản phẩm này
và thông tin sản phẩm ngoài ra sẽ có cả thể loại và nhà sản xuất nữa
a tiếp theo là bọn em có quản lý tin tức nên bọn em sẽ có cả tin tức và thể loại
tin tức thông tin của bài 5A à à Ờ Ờ
cái này thật là như tôi nó hôm trước gà hơi sai là tôi đã phải hiển thị ra cái
ảnh đầy đủ của bạn của thiết kế đã tầm bậy chứ không phải là liệt kê theo cậu
từng cái như thế này cái này thì ra chọn cân Bolivia mẹ các bạn không cần phải
Liệt kê lại tên tất cả các bạn mẹ tôi xin phép tôi nhảy sang bên anh tới bây cho bạn xem qua trước nha
thế này nó sẽ phải như này cơ ừ ừ
ở đâu còn chưa Sếp rồi coi tốt thôi chị người ông cách xếp luôn
số nhân viên lên trên này hạn xuất lên trên này sản phẩm rồi này hình ảnh độc
lập này tủ lạnh loại tin tức này
U19 hóa đơn chi tiết ở dưới sản phẩm này có thể loại sản phẩm cũng ở trên à
anh lại phải có nổi nữa nhưng mà tôi bảo hôm trước rồi quên không chuyển nó khó ngoại luôn Nói chung là tôi làm đồ ăn
bột có nhiều cái sơ xa lắm nếu không sẽ thời gian nhiều cái tôi làm đổi một số sáng mấy ông nên rút kinh nghiệm được
đấy à Hôm nay ông nhiều chữ hơn à Thế rồi
à cấp độ nhân khiến bạn Đây đây đây ý
nghĩa là mày không sẽ làm cái kiểu như này Sao nối nữa nhìn nó rõ thì cách
trình bày của ta ta bây theo như tôi Tôi muốn sinh viên ơi trình bày không quan
tâm chỗ khác trình bày nha nga thì à sẽ là mình có thể nói qua em lưu thông tin
nhân viên em lại không tin thông tin nhân viên trong bạn nhân viên đúng không Và em lưu
lại cấp độ nhân viên ở bảng riêng để về sau em muốn thêm thêm cấp độ nhân
viên ở thì em sẽ thêm thêm sửa xóa dễ tiếp theo là em có bằng sản thuật sản
phẩm này sẽ sẽ có thêm thông tin của nhà sản xuất và thể loại sản phẩm à
anh em cũng có tin tức và lưu lại thông tin Hình như lại loại tin tức nữa và có một
bảng ảnh để mà lưu lại slide và ở đây nếu mà khi khách hàng đặt hàng thì khách
hàng sẽ lưu lại thông tin khác đăng ký xong rồi lại thông tin trong bạn khách hàng này và khách hàng đặt hàng thì sẽ
tạo ra hóa đơn và một hóa đơn thì sẽ có như sản phẩm thì sẽ nối danh bảo hóa đơn
chi tiết nó sẽ lưu lại mã của hóa đơn mà mã sản phẩm mới biết được hoặc hóa đơn
đấy còn những sản phẩm gì và số lượng là bao nhiêu đấy và thường tí các bạn các
bạn là trình bày đến đoạn này xong thì các bạn nên dừng lại để mà cho giáo viên
sẽ hỏi qua những cái cột mà tại sao cuộc đấy lại có một đấy lại sợ có bạn đấy
bằng ấy để làm gì và Vân sẽ hỏi xem vụ này được ngoại
à à em chuyển ngay
em chưa Nhớ đến kết luận đó nhé đã lẽ Làm bây giờ sẽ nhảy sang demo cho mấy so
với xe xong rồi mới qua hướng mở rộng kết luận tới sẽ để xem demo nhé thì đây là trang web của bọn em
Bọn em muốn làm trang web về Gaming đây là sẽ dùng tông màu đen đo với tôi vẫn
bị chê về cái vụ đen đỏ có tiên khi vào thì thì sẽ hiển thị các
sản phẩm bạn sợ sản phẩm Mời thêm mới nhất và tin tức
Ngoài ra có những thời trang kiểu thông tin liên hệ và chính sách bảo hành các thứ nữa thì khách hàng có thể bấm vào
xem toàn bộ sản phẩm hoặc là xe mà toàn bộ phụ kiện có đây tìm kiếm
làm thì khách hàng có thể đăng nhập đăng ký rồi em ạ đặt sản phẩm anh ở đây bấm
để xem chi tiết này để xem giá khuyến mãi này là lừa đấy số ngẫu nhiên đấy
thì bây giờ xử án đặt Ừ chị Bọn em vẫn sẽ cho kiểu cho vào giỏ hàng
nhưng mà phải phải đăng nhập đã tối nhớ phải nó nhập nhầm Tại sao lại có muốn
đăng xuất này lửa vừa nãy vừa đấy hai phải nó nhập này thì có thể đăng ký đăng
ký em đã kiểm tra vaj để mà khách hàng bắt buộc phải điền mày cái thông tin này rồi
em có đăng nhập thử đăng nhập đi khi đăng nhập nháy vẫn hợp lệ buồn cười
vậy thiết kế Hồi này là tôi muốn cho mọi cho
sinh viên Xem khách nên thành ra mới hiển thị ra nhà em nhé thì thường là nó sẽ điều hướng về đây này đấy
ạ sau đó thì để em đặt hàng trà sữa em sẽ đặt này em thấy thay đổi số lượng em
nhập theo số lượng bao nhiêu này số lượng này rồi đấy không cho cảm thấy số lượng buồn
cười xã tất cả sáng vợ vậy ra hay chỉnh sửa làn da trong sửa rỡ giá Hình như là sửa
có khi có thay đổi giá tiền đấy không biết rồi đây Em thấy cho khách hàng nhập mà
khi nhập thông tin người nhận ở đây đại thường mặc định các đoạn này nó tự động
điên đấy Tôi không phải là người làm việc do hàng này tôi bảo rồi thành ra nó
tệ nhà đấy đấy rồi có thể ở đây để mua hàng thì mua xong rồi
Em nhìn anh không có nút ở đây mà bấm vào đây này bấm vào đây để ra hai cái
này xong rồi bấm đưa tiếp chị nào là sử khi khi đạt được hàng thì sẽ hiển
thị ra thông tin được sự mua hàng các thứ thứ Ừ nhưng mà hồi đấy à do người khác làm
đoạn này nó cho một tệ nhé mẹ Chưa nhưng chị không có đơn thì cả
300 hiển thị đơn vừa rồi là Hiển thị luôn bên hàng chi tiết đó Đây là đơn hàng trước kia chưa về đơn hàng bình
thường lắm ý Ê mày có thể xem thông tin cá nhân và thay đổi thông tin cá nhân này ngon
Thế Hiển thị đổi mật khẩu khách hàng thân thiện đâu ok thì thì đây là đây ở
bên khách hàng còn mới ăn mì thì sao anh Em sẽ đến bên admin à à
Anh An ninh pro bình thường rồi à
Anh đợi tin đội lốt inamine và log in amin pro khám hay cãi vãi chưởng
Ừ anh à à
ở đây là khi người đăng nhập vào admin thì em vẫn sẽ điều hướng đến trang chủ nhưng
mà có thể trên menu sẽ thay đổi nhưng có thể bấm vào bên quản lý ở đây ra sự là
sẽ thêm một sản phẩm trở lại đi a nay có thể ẩn thêm mà sản phẩm gì đó
Ừ thôi tôi không để mua máy này đâu nhé mà không tự hiểu cần phải để mua gì mà nó sẽ mấy ông sẽ có thể đến mua qua với
những cái một vài tính năng thôi không cần phải định mua hết toàn bộ đâu
anh nói chẳng nhớ cái loại gì luôn ok ở nhà tôi có phân loại đấy phần loại là
bài viết được lên trang chủ ấy không này cũng làm vậy thường á à
- tin tức quản lý hóa đơn này à
À thế à Nói chung là mấy ông cái cái mấy ông cần để lâu ấy thì nó chỉ đơn giản là
kiểu khách hàng đăng nhập và đăng ký đăng nhập vào như thế sau đó đặt hàng sau đó thì sang bên amply để mà xem cái
đơn hàng đấy Xong rồi duyệt nó cả sửa không cũng không có sữa sữa đi lấy
Ừ ông ấy cho sữa đơn vay trước hơi sai thì mình chỉ có duyệt đơn thôi đúng
không diệt Thủy Đơn có thử thử hãy thế thôi Thế ra cũng tương đối rồi
còn tính năng nào nữa mày không thể vượt qua à muốn khoe thì khỏe lại cơ bản như thế thì thế tôi bảo buổi thuyết trình
Nếu mà thuyết trình nói không thì có thể mất hơn 10 phút thôi còn nếu mà được
khỏi nữa thì sẽ tốn lên nhiều rồi sao mà à Ừ Ok bây giờ
ạ Bây giờ mới đến chuyên mục là khi nào mà gỗ mít nhé ý
ở nhóm kia vào giờ nào ạ
ở Hà Nội Đợi tí rồi mở cái thiện xk mỹ đã
Ừ nó tự trò mấy ông tự động và phòng
ừ ừ ông bà và ngọt nào nè
à à
ở đâu rồi ạ
ừ ừ [âm nhạc]
à à Ờ Ờ mấy ông vào để mà xem cũng được vào
xem được mấy ông nên tắt tiếng đi thôi ờ ờ
À hôm nay nhóm nào muốn tự nguyện bảo vệ thì tôi tôi cho là mới bảo vệ mà
ừ ừ ừ ừ
anh nhìn có cái tiện ích sĩ mãi hai nhóm mẹ mau len bảo vệ chữa nhỏ mau
Đang Đủ Thành Viên đi nghỉ
Ừ đúng rồi thực ra là sửa đấy thì cũng thể chấp nhận được sửa hóa đơn vẫn chấp nhận được nhưng mà ờ ờ
thì ra là cái vấn đề làm chuyện xấu hơn thì ra muốn làm sửa sửa thông tin của
khách hàng sửa được những nhưng mà mình phải lưu lại cái lịch sử đã sửa nó ổn
hơn anh hả Anh tên của nó đúng như cái tính năng
của nó đây Google Mít I thought omote
ôtô xác nhận đây hay mà không chữa tôi tôi bảo ông chưa bỏ được
ở nhóm Mau lanh đủ người cho nghỉ để mình Anh bảo vệ luôn cũng được
em đổi màu là ăn rồi ô hay tôi phát âm sai tên Đông Á
à à à à
à à từ hạt Đúng rồi chưa anh không rõ được à
nghe tiếng mấy ông cũng phải cải thiện về âm thanh địa nha nghe nó cứ bị vai
hay do tôi nhỉ chờ
đợi tí cho tôi phải mấy ông có nghe rõ có
mỗi mình em bị ba rồi anh thích à anh Alo Em thử nói lại xem
anh alo
à à à à
à à ờ ờ Ừ anh vừa cắm tai nghe vào laptop rồi
Các bạn thử nói xem anh có nghe thấy không
Ừ ừ Mỹ ra cái này hơi khó xe online có cái lợi ở điểm là à
cho mấy bạn không ở nhìn mặt trực tiếp các bạn thì các bạn không run lắm ấy nhận như thế có phải cậu phải đứng trước
đám đông nhưng mà nhược điểm và các bạn có thể chưa Chuẩn bị đầy đủ với mic các
thứ Ai có tiền khó phải ai có tiền mua mấy đâu
à à Anh mau lanh Thử nói lại xem xem có ổn hơn chưa
Ừ ông ấy mất tích rồi ừ ừ
em cảm nhận hơi khó nghe nhỉ hơi bị ồn đấy
Ừ anh đeo tai nghe cũng chẳng nghe rõ em nói gì luôn à
khi con điện thoại đi Nick điện thoại tốt hơn mic laptop đấy ạ
ừ ừ
ở khó nhỉ à cho tôi quên tình cái trường hợp đấy Ôi
chị đang tình ở trường hợp là không ai dám bảo vậy thôi không không tình ơi trường hợp việc à
các bạn nick nick tao thử
Ừ nhưng mà chỉ tí được má đúng không ạ ừ ừ
ạ Bây giờ em on vào bàn cả điện thoại và laptop với sau đó đi ỉa tắt tiếng laptop đi cho
dùng điện thoại để mà mở máy điện thoại thôi là được Ăn mít có thể mở được trên điện thoại mà
Anh ở quên chưa bảo các bạn chuẩn bị mấy cái này nữa rồi rút kinh nghiệm hôm nay bảo vệ được lần 1 mà tôi kinh nghiệm sâu
sắc mấy cái vấn đề này
Ê mày nhóm ca buổi sau lưu ý à Nếu thế kiểm tra mic trước này kiểm tra
mở sẵn PowerPoint đã gà mở sẵn trang web rồi như mình mở đến hoa để mà demo cho
nhanh nhé
ừ ừ
ừ ừ khi bé tỉnh nào khi cây shop
à à Ừ thôi nhóm Block A
em kết bạn Huỳnh Châu à trâu minh chứng minh mà chưa
a cho mình tải à có nhóm nào muốn tình nguyện trước không
nhỉ
đã quy khô dài mất tích rồi ở lớp trưởng đạo này mới thì thôi
à à
ừ ừ ừ ừ
I run run gì Cái cái thuyết trình này để
mục đích để để cho những cái bạn Mà đang run để mà quen mà đúng không
em chưa phải mục đích là kiểu dành cho các bạn chuyên nghiệp sẵn rồi đâu nếu mà chuyên nghiệp sẵn rồi các bạn cần gì để
bảo vệ thử đúng không Thế mà bảo vệ thật nữa đấy do mà tôi bảo
là trường tới thành công là Địa Bà ý là cho sinh viên ba lần bảo vệ
anh như thế thì lần đầu lúc nào toa sẽ trả lên một lúc nào toàn nếu mà lần 2 sẽ
ổn hơn và lần 3 thì nó giờ chuyên nghiệp rồi và khi đi phỏng vấn này đi thực tập
thì các bạn đấy đã quen rồi các bạn bớt run hơn chú chó
la la lần đầu qua sóng Run
từ khóa tiếp theo là khóa nâng cao xảy ra sau chắc phải đến tháng 3 tháng 4 đấy
Ừ rồi các bạn vậy không phải là mạnh Bạn lên các bạn vậy Nghĩ rằng à Ai cũng như
mình thôi không phải sao cả Em hãy coi như đi làm gái à
Ừ thế hệ Chắc để gái Tan Mất
Ừ ông Châu Minh kia biến mất rồi à
gà con một nhóm gồm màu led nhóm Mau Lan ý
nghe có ông Hira đúng không đi ra là Thành Long đúng không
Em có nhớ thế mà đúng không ở đây cho mình có mất rồi
à à
vì vậy vậy Nhóm 21 bảo vệ chỗ nhé Nhóm 31 bảo vệ
à à Anh nhường trước à chị thu nhập các bạn ấy
không không có nhiều người đây cả Một chồng hai đâu nhanh nào
Ừ thôi cho nhỏ mà hay mốt bảo vệ chơi
Ừ thôi tin tưởng lớp trưởng anh Alo Alo em techniques có nghe rồi
anh lắm alo ổn em ơi Ok
Ừ rồi Thế thì bảo vệ luôn thôi à
à à anh làm sao mình vẫn còn đang theo kiểu
là nửa nghiêm túc nữa tí nữa thoải mái mà hôm bảo vệ thật thì
mới ở cần rất nghiêm túc từ hôm nay thằng chữa màn hình
Ừ ok à à à quên quên đó là thuyết trình mà
vừa rồi anh thuyết trình một mình còn nếu mà cái trình hai người sẽ là mỗi người phải nói nữa nhé chứ không phải
một người nói từ đầu tiên cô ấy đúng không anh bị gì rồi à
Ừ ông xã buổi đầu thì sẽ trả lời là nhiều người còn còn nó lắm
à à chị sẽ chia sẻ
anh ấy em đi bộ phận là Ryan tôi thì chứ
chưa chuẩn bị gì hết chứ A Không ý là phần thuyết trình slide ấy thì thì mỗi
người nói một nửa em còn về để mô thì thì ai làm phần nào
thì sẽ đến mua phần đấy sẽ trình phần đấy Ừ
cái gì ta số xổ số Nam
Cho tôi mở cánh bạc trên mặt bánh bao hai này
3 4 5 tết cho iPhone 6 đi mô rồi
hai kỹ thuật bắn gà vịt cơ sở hiểu đi á Tôi bắt đầu Dần nữa vậy
ok cái chị ạ Thôi rồi Xin chào mừng các bạn đã đến phần cái
trình của nhóm 21 thành nhóm mình Nhằm đề tài rất là sắp bắn cá online à nhóm
gồm hai thành tiên đó chính là mình là những chữ và tên Châu là thành viên
à À đi cho mình chọn đề tài đó chính là dạo này công nghệ rất là phát triển cho
nên khóc shop đều chỉ có bán hàng online và để Sao kỳ theo kịp xu hướng ấy thì đã
quyết định nộp đề tài bảo hành Online Thà
với nhu cầu mua áo tăng cao thì rất xấu rất khó mà để quản lý cũng như doanh thu
cũng như nhân sự và một phần là nhóm em để học tập
Ê mày không nghe giọng thì chúng em dùng pin
3.41 well until mail.nam Java Script
s2015 và CS em về đối tượng thì khách hàng còn gót
chức năng chưa có tài khoản có thằng đã có tài khoản và nhân viên quản lý
xin chào Minh cài đặt iPhone mini
anh alo alo à à
khu vực thương em ta đang nghe đang nghe đi
Chú mèo đi làm sao đâu ừ ừ
Để ủng em em nhưng mà em cứ nói đi Em cứ nói đi
ok Ừ thì phần khách hàng chứ có tài khoản
thì có 3 tính năng mà em muốn giới thiệu có đó là phần Đăng nhập phần đăng ký và
phân tìm kiếm A và phần khách hàng có tài khoản thì sẽ
có phần đăng nhập đăng kí xem tất cả sản phẩm và tìm kiếm và phần đánh giá sản
phẩm ừ ừ cho rằng nhân viên thì có các tính năng
chính đó chính là đăng nhập đăng xuất bạn làm mật khẩu xem tầm quan xem thêm sữa xóa sản phẩm xem và thay đổi thành
vật đơn về phòng quản lý thì đăng nhập có đăng nhập đăng xuất đặt lại mật khẩu sang
động con xem thêm sẽ xóa sản phẩm xem thêm sẽ xóa nhân viên xem em sợ xóa xăm
nhà sản xuất và xem thay đổi tình trạng đơn thì
ở đây là sơ đồ cụ thể của nhóm em
bộ phim à hay là cái sơ đồ cơ sở dữ liệu của nhóm
em ạ anh không không không phải thuyết trình
hay cái đấy đấy Không không phải đạt từ phải nói Tại sao lại nói như thế Tại sao
Còn những cái đấy ở phòng hình ảnh à
ở trẻ sẽ Z1 khỏa thân này
ông kia nói cách chụp không ê ê
a ph hả Không không hiển thị được con chuột đúng không
để em Cái chai vậy anh à Ừ Từ khách hàng thì khi cái thằng
Đăng ký và tạo tài khoản thì nó sẽ nhà
đất tại đâu và bạn customer còn có ID tên giới tính ngày sinh email password
iPhone và địa chỉ và talking
Sau khi Cách thằng đang đăng ký và đăng nhập thì khách hàng sẽ mua
và nó sẽ lưu vào phần điêu hợp biểu tiếp
theo I I'm khi và sau khi thích thằng đã Hoa Kỳ sẽ
đánh giá sản phẩm và Google bảo lưu và đánh giá và vẫn Please press
ở cấp các sản phẩm mà khách hàng mua sẽ có trong bản đồ đất
khi cài đặt ạ số hạt là lạ trong tầm
các lại sản phẩm của Urus sẽ lên vào bonsai
cách làm à chợ Tân Minh thì nhân viên sẽ được lưu
vào bổng em lo gì gồm có ID tên số điện
thoại địa chỉ tính ngày sinh email mốc
level nên là cấp bậc của nhân viên
và Token minor ID là người đã theo nhân viên
I I'm khi các em like Paris là để làm cái view
để hạn chế truy vấn của em
Ừ để bộ trong bếp à
khi đến điểm để vào trang web à à
ờ ờ quay quay quay quay lại đi quay lại để anh thử hỏi phát điện
cô bạn kia vợ bảo là à full screen
Ừ đợi đến tí anh thử bấm cái nút gì để xem được cả màn hình của em nhé Anh không thấy có chút gì được Bấm xem cả
mình em với bộ phim Coi phim
Ừ ok Nói chung nhà rồi thì ra Ừ đợi tí quay quay lại đấy
à à chị xem nào á Đợi tí nhé
Ừ ok ok Ừ cảm ơn nhé Mình chưa dùng quen hay gặp ở
ở đầu tiên là không không còn không cần phải liệt kê đầy đủ tên tất cả cuộc đâu có ai là à
Ừ anh thấy ở đây như có bạn nói đang bị thiếu khóa Ngoại đúng không làm thiếu nối khoáng ngoại tại sao lại thiếu hoa
ngoại nhỉ anh em chưa nói thế hơi sai vì mình học cơ sở dữ liệu
này là cơ sở dữ liệu quan hệ là phải khó dặm một khóa ngoại các thử nữa
hỗ trợ Tiếp theo là cái bảng Android querrey ở để làm gì nhỉ Em view để giới
hạn tư vấn không thể không cần để mình tạo hoàn view hoặc à mình sẽ tạo thành file riêng
chứ không nên bị V kết dữ liệu như thế Nghe ca nhạc Vì sao phải xóa cái bảng ở đi tiếp theo
à ô tô cân là điểm gì nhỉ Tao Ken có tao
kem customer đó tao kem em.loi để làm gì nhỉ để đăng nhập nhanh đi
cho cơ thể Nó hoạt động như nào rồi mà cho em dùm anh lấy Talking là em lấy
email + password xong khi mà ghi nhớ đăng nhập thì sẽ dùng truy vấn một tô
kênh cho nhanh à à Nữa lưu lại giống kiểu kia đúng không hiểu kiểu để mà đang
ghi nhớ Đăng nhập thôi đúng không ạ Ừ ok
Ê status của Bill để là để làm gì nhỉ ở đó là gì đang chờ chị ạ
Ngữ Văn thế hả Đang chờ duyệt hủy
thì tại sao nói hại kiểu là thai nhi in Ừ tại vì nó có ba đặc Thái em dùng số
cho À à người em quy ước Nó sổ luôn đúng không ạ
ừ ừ Ở đây anh thấy à em khác mày nhóm khác
là có thêm cột xô đã bán à trong bạc có đắt thì làm gì nhé
a sone à hát là đã bán để xem số lượng hàng đã
mua
Ừ cái này nó còn liên quan đến cái con tivi không nghĩa là kiểu gì cả cờ dạng
con Ti là số lượng còn lại hay là số lượng nhập về I want it I là số lượng còn lại
thế hệ có giờ có kiểm tra vụ là số lượng còn lại hết không nhỉ kể cả các phần
trăm sáng Quang Ừ ok
Ừ rồi sao để môi à à i i
à à ca nhạc ta đi mua để em xem màn hình được không
thấy để em em có thể chụp ảnh màn hình của em ạ
à à phụ kiện
à à à à ở bảng giá thấy màn hình của em chị ạ
Ừ rồi em ok Ô kìa Thì phần của khách hàng thì đầu
tiên là về phần khách hàng khách hàng bảo lái khách hàng chứ có tài khoản thì phần này em sẽ có phần là đăng ký nhắn
cho đăng ký dành cho khách hàng trong phần này thì em có kiểm tra kiểm tra họ tên
khi mà đánh kiểm tra các thông tin vào khi mà nhấn nút đăng ký thì nó sẽ hiện lên cái phần vai biết để kiểm tra thông
tin em cũng có cháo nói chuyện nhanh
di chuyển nhanh qua giữa 2 phần đăng nhập và đăng ký ở khi mà ấn nút này ở An
phần trên này tiếp theo là phần đăng nhập thì phần này thì Anh ở trang và đăngnhập chị em có cũng
có kiểm tra thông tin với vides à và khi khi mà đăng nhập đúng
đã đăng nhập xài thì nó có hiện thông báo đi a What the you
à à khi thực hiện thông báo lên bên này cũng giống như phần là đăng ký cũng vậy
thì khi mà thành công thì nó sẽ sẽ sẽ hiển thị là đăng ký thành công hoặc là
đăng nhập thành không a tiếp theo là về phần là xét về khả năng và tìm kiếm thì
chị mà tìm kiếm một từ khoản nợ ở trên này thì khi bạn đăng enter thì nó sẽ lọc
đà các thông tin và nó nhìn thấy kết quả ở phần phần phần dưới đây
a tiếp theo là phần là à cho tất cả iPhone lọc đặc sản phẩm cho
đi phân lỏng này thêm em lọc theo à hải sản xuất loại chặn lại sản phẩm và giá
khi mà áp dụng thì nó cũng sẽ hiện kết quả ngày luôn à
em xin chuyển quá cái phần là chỉ dành cho khách hàng đã qua tan hoạt
thì khi đăng nhập vào anh ghi em đàn Dạo này nó thì nó sẽ hiện
cái thông tin đăng nhập thành công trong cái phần này chị về phân lọc và
phần sửa thì nói giống với khách hàng chưa có tài khoản và và tiếp theo thì em
xin trình bày khi phần mà cái này cái này là thông tin của thông tin của
cho khách hàng trong phần này sẽ có cập nhật và xóa tài khoản
và cập nhật thì em sẽ đi mua là nếu mà
cập nhật thì nó sẽ hiển thị Anh công và nó sẽ rất là để lát loại cây cành nhà
ra khỏi cái càng à ảnh của xứ sở này và nó cập nhật Linh
đặt tay rồi mình về a tiếp theo là về phần à
x em đánh nhầm em nhé tiếp theo là phần về phần điều hành à
ừ ừ khi mà không tiếp theo là về phần à
Xem thông tin của sản phẩm là khi em vào đây trà Nó sẽ hiển đến thông tin của một bộ
sản phẩm và hiện lên cái rate Cái này gọi là bình luận và đánh
giá sản phẩm thì cái này cũng giống như phần của khách hàng chỉ có tài khoản
nhưng mà về phần của khách hàng có tài khoản thì nó sẽ có thêm vào thêm giao
hàng ở khi anh và thêm điều hành thì sẽ nó sẽ đặt một cái
31 các sản phẩm và hệ điều hành và nó sẽ hiện lên đây
mình em sẽ vào phần giữa hàng về tham dự hàng
thì sẽ có xóa và tăng sản phẩm hoặc là đặt hàng hoặc là xóa tất cả
thì có s để mỗi phần hành đ
sau khi đặt hàng thì nó sẽ tự động điền thông tin của mình lên và mình ấn nút
đặt hàng thì nó sẽ hỏi mình là các bạn có đặt hàng không Ok
Ờ nó bị lỗi gì Tại vì em vẫn chưa biết sau khi đặt hàng xong thì qua phần đơn
hàng phần ngân hàng sẽ hiển thị cho mình thấy đó là ghê cái thông tin của mình
thông tin mà đang đặt hàng thì có tình trạng tình cảm đơn đây là đã chơi được
đơn sau khi ăn vào à một trong số này thì nó sẽ hiển thị lên cho mình
anh buồn đấy thì nó sẽ hiển thị lên cái cái thông tin
của sản phẩm mà em đã thẳng cái này nó bị lỗi gì Em quên mất tiền chị ạ
và cái này là chèn file cho đường link chuyển file bị lỗi phẩm xong ta tiếp đi
Dạ À về phận Batman thông tin khách hàng thì
em sẽ đến bố phần cho tài khoản sẽ tài khoản thì nó sẽ hiển thị lên cho
mình gọi là thôi tôi không không không không cần để một từ ngày ok bây giờ Dạ có khách hàng làm được thêm gì nữa không
em trẻ em xin hết vần khách hàng hết khi các hãng hết hết
hết Ok Ok bạn kia để mua phần à bên à
ở bên Admin làm được những gì đấy à à à à
ừ ừ ừ ừ
ở đây là giao diện của admin admin sẽ có hai cái là nhân viên và quản
lý em sẽ để một sức mạnh của nhân viên à về nhân viên thì mình sẽ xem được tổng
quan thống kê doanh thu
hoạt động và thông tin kho
khi khách hàng tìm nhanh và sản phẩm tiêu biểu
nhân viên sẽ xem được các mặt hàng chị xem các mặt hàng được thêm mặt hàng
Ừ tao đó là có thêm giúp file Excel
xe tải về
à à sản xuất về phytol và có thể hiện việc
trả phí đơn hàng à Ừ thế này có phải
tạo bên thằng trong điện thoại em hết đơn vừa đặt đâu rồi
ở đảo của ông mái che mặt thải Ừ đúng rồi Thế thì à
anh em em không có đơn nào mà mới mới đặt à à
Ừ thôi nó không Thế bỏ qua bỏ quá à
tỷ lệ Còn còn tính năng gì nữa ở Bệnh bên kia mới còn thật
xe máy super nữa Ừ thì bật lên bờ mi nói đi
à à anh ở bên Superman sẽ có thêm nhân viên
sửa và xóa nhân viên à à và tên nhà sản xuất sữa nhà sản xuất
thời điểm các mặt hàng nội thất Thanh chéo xuống i
em hết rồi đúng không Ai có quên mật khẩu được tiền không à quên mật khẩu thì làm như nào
hỗ trợ ký email Ừ Ok thôi thể thấy cũng biết rồi tình cờ
em coi lại bên like nói về hướng mở rộng là cái luận đi ạ
à à Tất nhiên là phải sai
anh thích gọi là nhóm em đã làm được CRD cơ bản gửi email và xuất file Excel à
[âm nhạc] ừ ừ
ờ ờ không không có hướng mở rộng nhà mới
mở rộng rất là sử là nhiều hơn mở rộng ở phía trên
Anh ơi chết như vậy quyền lực mở rộng ơi
thiết kế thừa thử nói trai lại đấy hướng mở rộng thì đầu tiên thì hỏi nhóm trưởng
nữa đi theo em thì trang web của em có thể làm được thêm những cái gì
Linh kế nên Google Maps chị
xem hay iPod à cho xem
thí sinh nhật cho nhà tắm Ừ anh hiểu ta à
ừ ừ có cái gì đó đi
Ừ cái còn nhóm phó rằng nhóm phó Thì nghĩa là cần thêm tính năng gì ở bên
khách hàng à Dạ em nhỉ Chắc thêm phần nào post với lại thêm các phần Natri nghi vấn sản
phẩm đã cho khách hàng à ở ga vừa rồi thì anh mới chỉ cho các bạn
thấy chỉ rồi Anh vẫn chưa ném đá gì cả ở nhà ở xây xã anh anh sẽ ném đá sau
ở buổi bảo vệ Hử với anh muốn các bạn bớt run đã Buổi bảo vệ thật thì anh ném
đá thậm tệ sau nhé ok bây giờ tiếp sang nhỏ mà ngắm tiếp theo nhóm 31 đi
à à số nhà 31 rồi còn đây không
anh alo alo à à
em là con
ok à khi bạn bắt đầu thôi em cứ bình tĩnh
thôi ở [âm nhạc]
đâu rồi lại về mất rồi ngắm mày hay mất tích rồi
không biết làm sao được chị ạ Ừ anh chưa thấy gì cả
không phải đi làm à
bí ẩn chia sẻ không không lên được có thể là do là trần thị xem điện
nói rõ trình duyệt thiếu quyền đánh thử mở lại trình duyệt quyền Admin cho
mình sẽ đi chưa thì thấy rồi em ơi Thế thôi
anh ạ Vì sao em xin phát trình bày về vụ án
của nhóm chính năm em làm về website bán hàng sản phẩm gia dụng thì nó nhói Minh Chính Là Em là nó Trưởng Văn Long
thì chắc là tài thì nhưng nó ra đó là sống hiện nay chị buôn bán thì người ta cái xe lại sách để nhận những gì Các bạn
và nhìn khách hàng em thấy là sự thế này nó sẽ dự án và đã sai này về cho mình
tại thì khách hàng đặt hàng khi này là hàng thì mà còn thằng Dũng nó Excel bắt đầu tiên là các ngân hàng phải đưa ra
thị mật khẩu trong Access dữ liệu bất tiện đàn bà khi mỗi khi gặp theo sản phẩm mới thêm một và mới thì đều phải đi
thêm một bản khi đó anh xem của em
cũng như là thống kê quản lý bảo xem lịch sử
sử dụng thì một em có bốn nó sẽ sử dụng đầu tiên là khoảng bao like từ đó là
khách hàng có tài khoản và nhân viên cục diện và Quản trị hệ thống thì về các nhà bảo ai thì có gì anh sẽ
rất nhanh sau đó là sẽ tất cả sản phẩm các sản phẩm của chị tiết hơn và cho tìm
kiếm sản phẩm mà chức năng Đăng nhập đăng ký là khách hàng có tài khoản thì bao Còn chị chức năng như là sẽ tất cả các sản phẩm cho rằng chi tiết tìm kiếm
sản phẩm đăng nhập đăng ký năng suất đặt hàng giả hàng địa chỉ nhận hàng mà cô đơn
về nhân viên cần duyệt chỉ có những chức năng sau đó là bao gồm Đăng nhập đăng xuất của sản phẩm mà xem thêm chỉnh sửa
còn hóa đơn cần phải có đơn có gì Gắn thẻ bảo nguồn Xem phim sẽ xóa mà sẽ bị xao động về quản lý là những người có hệ
thống thì có các bạn của nhân viên kiểm duyệt thì thích năng đó là xóa sản phẩm quản lý cung cấp Xem thống kê bỏ đi xe
khách hàng còn là sau đây thì em xin phép để bạn là Ngọc Trình bày một phần
sao ạ
ở nhà Khi mà mình à
[âm nhạc]
[Vỗ tay] Ừ
ông ơi YouTube rồi ông ơi anh alo alo
em nghe rồi em nói tiếng muốn hai giữa
hóa đơn và nhân viên thì một hóa đơn thì được xử lý bởi một nhân viên thôi Nên là
mối quan hệ giữa hóa đơn và những việc là 11 về một nhân viên thì có thể giữ nhiều hóa
đơn cùng một lúc có thể hiểu như phản ứng có nên là mỗi hệ giữa nhân viên hội đồng là một nửa về mối quan hệ giữa
khách hàng và hóa đơn thì một cái hàng có thể có nhiều hóa đơn nè Khách hàng muốn vay giữa các em vào đây
là một nhờ vào đơn mỗi đơn thì chỉ có thể thuộc về một cái đèn này là
Anh muốn về vợ mà thôi đó và thấy hay là một người hết lòng tiếp tục
đây này có sơ đồ cơ sở dữ liệu mà ạ
Ừ dạo này em tao nói thêm gì không ạ ạ
anh em Em cứ nói đi ừ
anh alo Long anh à
ờ ờ
ở đây là em có các bạn ví dụ như là bản bạn manifesto là bạn nghe cung cấp nó có
khó chính đối với nối với cái bảng sản phẩm
đi lễ cha mẹ của nhà sản xuất về cái bảng sản phẩm đối với các bạn hóa
đơn và bố cục mẹ của sản phẩm về
ở bản Sản phẩm còn được nói với bạn thể loại của sản phẩm đó là cùng với cái mẹ
của sản phẩm về mẹ về mẹ con sẽ cắn thì nó với
với bạn ạ các bạn nghịch đèn dịch bạn sản phẩm bạn
thể là sản phẩm được nối với Bản thể loại que cục ID của thể loại
đề tài hóa đơn thì đừng nói với bạn hóa đơn chi tiết về
mẹ của hóa đơn còn đè bẹp bẹp hóa đơn thì nói với bạn Khách hàng về
quê em mặc make up cha mẹ của à Này em có hai cái bạn không đi lén ở
trên giấy nhìn bạn để lưu thông tin của nhân viên bạn về
quản lý và bảo vệ tinh dễ Ở đây lương tại hợp đồng của bên size
Mini Galaxy Note Ok em ờ
Ừ anh thấy thích mũi à vì thế cuối em đói thôi Nó là em nói cụ
thể là bàn để làm gì chứ không cho ta không cần nói lại tên cột với các bạn
nói như nào nhìn hình cảm rõ rồi mà em thấy nó khá dài dòng nhưng mà liệt kê rồi đồng đấy đúng không Thế nên là không
cần phải trình bày mấy cái để làm gì cả nhìn vào người ta lên hình dung vừa rồi
mình sẽ Chị nói là tại sao lại có bảng này bằng này tồn tại để em Duy bà này
Tại sao nối bảng kia Tại sao thế đúng không ờ ờ
Ok ở đây à Rồi anh định hỏi bà tt nhà em giải thích rồi nó bảo để mà lưu lại hoạt
động của An Ninh đúng không Tại sao nó không lưu lại tại sao nó không nói khóa ngoại với bằng an ninh mà
ai giày da lúc lúc này nếu in Xóa apnee thì Ừ nếu mày là trứng có hỏi thì không thể
xóa được đã hj cơ nhảy Lúc này em có thể thêm một
nhân viên mới xong rồi sau đó thêm sẽ thả những viên đó thì nếu mà Nhân viên
đó để có những tt ở trong admin thì còn
gọi nó không thể xóa nó không thể sống được ai ai bên đó không thể xóa được nhân vật đó đúng rồi Thế là thực ra là
chúng ta không nên xóa nhân viên mà chúng ta có thể thêm 1 cột nữa rồi còn khóa nhân viên này nó sẽ hợp lý hơn đúng
không Thì cái em vừa nói cũng là một cái mà gạo cho ở anh thấy à hình như anh thấy chưa có nhóm nào làm
Đó là kiểu mình đến khóa thay vì xóa một cái gì bỏ đi chỉ đơn giản là cậu không cho nó không cho khách hàng hay ở nhân
viên rồi có khuya nữa truy cập tài khoản nữa thì nó hợp lý hơn đúng không Ok ở
đây cũng có bạn đang hỏi cái câu mà mảnh định hỏi đó là ở kia có bảng 2 port Type
và có đắt 3 bảng đấy ừ ừ thì tại sao bị lỗi nhau nhỉ
ở tập vram đó một sản phẩm có nhiều thể
loại ở một sản phẩm này cần được thể nói về một thể loại thì có thể được gắn bao
nhiêu sản phẩm nó là em đã tạo nên một cái bản trung gian áp restore à Ok và có bảng receiver ghê làm gì nhé
ở nhà em restore
ai giống ai giúp tôi bên này à
anh Alo Alo ạ
ừ ừ A gọi
Ông giúp tôi đi ship ơi Chị bảo em tạo ra là bắt đầu mik là để
quản lý nhân viên quản lý cái địa chỉ người nhận rõ ràng hơn khi mà đáp án
ý em ở Quản lý như thế nào nhỉ em thấy nó rõ hơn nữa kiểu như là
em tạo ra thì có thể quản lý việc thay đổi được mà đặt mặc định khi mà em đặt
hàng thế mà chọn nhiều không phải là việc ở tạm khi mỗi lần 11 lần mà các
hàng thì phải ta là một cái em điền các thông tin về người địa chỉ nhận sẽ chọn rồi em tạo sẵn em
ừ ừ khi sex Ừ Anh hiểu ý em ở nhưng mà em không tận
dụng được điều đấy nên là nó hơi bị sai một tí ở đây Tí em có em có bắt đầu từ
rộng là liên kết cái bàn VSIP nhưng mà sau khi đó em nhận ra là nếu mà em thay
đổi thông tin của các bạn ấy Siv thì bảo ship cái những cái J cũng sẽ bị đuổi heo
cho anh Anh hiểu ý em Đúng rồi em em nhận ra được cái đấy là
một cái cũng hay nữa thế là chúng ta kiểu Xipo để mà nối xanh Nếu mà nối xanh
thì cái đơn cũ nó bị ảnh hưởng đúng không ạ
ừ nếu thế thì mình có thể là có một cách đó là mình sẽ đắp đi kết cái receiver
lên Ừ cũng được để mà lưu lại khi mà khách
hàng thay đổi bản chất là khách hàng có thể không thay đổi được cái thông tin cũ
mà phải tạo hẳn với thông tin mới chẳng qua là ẩn thông tin cũ đi cũng được ẩn
đi em Em hiểu ý anh không thì nó lại không không không bị lập dữ liệu nữa Thế
thì có thể theo một cái cổ nữa vào bảo vệ sinh còn đúng rồi thêm một cột là cột ẩn đi thì khách hàng thì không được thay
đổi thông tin địa chỉ cũ bởi vì nó nối sang những người và đơn cũ mà đúng không Thì thì nó thì khách hàng có thể ẩn đi
cũng là một ý thì chị sẽ không phải lặp lại dữ liệu ý anh à Đây là một cách thôi
để mà việc mình tránh việc bị lập lại dữ liệu đúng không ạ Ok Anh anh ấy à nhóm
này có vẻ thiết kế ra bậy khá là ổn rồi trình bày cũng được rồi Nếu mà sửa lại slide Cài
mấy cái slide đầu ô chữ quả đúng không Rồi sang bên đề modi
em xin phép khách hàng
sản phẩm
tiếp theo đó là đề trên đăng ký
[âm nhạc] thành công còn nếu đăng ký
anh
không Yêu cầu này đủ các thông tin về
thông tin
email
chỉ là tổng thì xác khi bắn vào đây thì nó sẽ tất cả
thông tin về sản phẩm còn phải đăng nhập thì nếu liền sai định dạng của Email thì nó
sẽ không gặp được sẽ yêu cầu là nhận đúng dạng email
em sẽ ẩn hiện dùng Hungary ẩn đi và hiện nay nó mới
vào mà cũng thông báo thành công thì sao đây là thành công thì ở xong trang sản
phẩm chi tiết thì sẽ hiện thấy nó là thêm vào giỏ hàng mà trang chủ Khi nào tiện thì
điện thoại thế mà giờ hàng thì sản lượng số lượng của các sản phẩm trở lên một trong vàng
tăng giảm xóa Ngoài ra thì khi mà số lượng là xuống
không thì sản phẩm định xóa đi vào bảng sau đi theo
nè đó cho em đặt hàng chị đặt hàng thì em sẽ dùng hiện cả chỉ
là người nhận Đây như nãy em với chị ạ chị ngoài ra thì có thể là thay đổi
thì cái thông tin của người này sao đổi ngôi ở phần bên này
chưa thành xong thì nó sẽ chuyển vào là đơn hàng đang chờ xét duyệt
đơn hàng thì em có đưa ra 6 số điện thoại đó là sẽ thiệt không Việt đang
giao hàng đã hàng sao thành công đã bị gì Hà Hồ khi ở trang trại được này thì
nó phải sang suất ngân hàng là một cái gì Và ra sản phẩm ví dụ như là thông tin được nhập
có thể là ấn qua tên sản phẩm để xem chi tiết không đi chơi nữa hả Phẩm
nó ra chỉ có thể là quy đơn hàng như chỉ nó sử dụng đã hủy và thông báo và xóa đẹp thành công
đi về địa chỉ giao hàng thì em có
xem Tạo xóa sửa và cho mạnh cho con định là sẽ khi mà đặt hàng cho chị phép Nên
là nhưng em thấy được là
ok thử đặt một đơn sau đó thì à đặt một đơn em em hủy em nghỉ rồi Đạt
lại được hơn thi ạ ạ ạ ạ
Ừ
thôi anh em biết cái này rồi khách khách hàng còn làm gì nữa không Không thì cá
nhân Ừ ok Còn còn gì nữa không nhỉ
Thôi thôi Ok đã sang bạn kia để mua về ăn mini
đẹp à
ờ ờ
Ma Kết quá
rẻ mọi người thấy màn hình của anh chưa rồi anh rồi
Nghe nhạc giao diện đăng nhập anh đi im cái Cái
Phong đăng nhập lại em chưa cho chú công ty ấy lắm
rồi đăng nhập vào thì ở trang chủ của mình thì mình sẽ thấy được kia thống kê
bốn cái bảng thống kê cơ bản của của một cây một cái tủ hen à Đó là thống
kê doanh thu gần đây em 10 ngày gần đây ở với các sản phẩm bán được ở các hóa đơn trong trạng thái trong 10 ngày gần
đây ạ về cái thích về cái biểu đồ Thiện ở suối tiên của các rẽ đầu tư vào cửa
hàng của mình em kia cái hạn mình xa thành 3 phần đó
là về nhà cung cấp ở đây là liên quan tới ở nhà sản xuất cung cấp sản phẩm
trai của em của mình về vùng nội bộ thì có những mục tiêu nè quản lý sản phẩm với hóa đơn quản lý về cái anh lên sản
phẩm huyện Lý Nhân viên về một vài thống kê về một cuộc đời đó là quản lý khách hàng
phần quản lý di sản xuất thì mình có thể xem
nó có thể tìm kiếm theo tên của nhà sản xuất ví dụ như là khi
thì nó sẽ win Viettel keton
đây còn có sẵn sàng ở mình có thể nhấn vào để xin chứ ở nhà sản xuất đó
ví dụ ở đây thì có một cơ thể thay đổi này tổng số tiền thu được từ sản phẩm
của nhà cung cấp này về cây sản phẩm tiêu biểu của nhà cung cấp đó
em có thể thêm nhà cung cấp mới lại ở đây là chức năng của quản lý ngành chức
năng liên quan tới em chỉ có thể chị quản lý có thể quên được thôi còn nhân viên của trường không thể về rồi
ở vùng được bộ thì ở Vịnh em có thể xem tất cả các sản phẩm ở đây
tìm kiếm phần trăm ví dụ như là tìm Trỗi
chúng ta sẽ vẫn trơn lại trỗi dậy
về tìm kiếm em có thể xem chi tiết về sản phẩm đó
mình có thể thấy mình cơ thể suy nhược ở số sản phẩm bán được về tổng số tiền thu
được từ đó về lần quý cùng mua được cái thể được gắn lên sản phẩm này
về bạn lấy hóa đơn thì em vứt ở đây là phần của Lý Hóa đường của th video của
cơ thể a cho tôi bác sĩ thông báo ở đây đây + hóa đơn trên cầu
về mình cũng có thể bắt đầu trực tiếp là khi mà khách ở Kim hàng sản phẩm tới tay
của khách ăn thì giải bằng cách nào đó thì
là mình sẽ tải ứng giá thành câu chứ không có tự động ứng với thành công được
mình cũng có thể nghĩ đến hàng
về mình có thể xin chi tiết đơn hàng nè trong đó có những sản phẩm nào về đầu tiên của sản phẩm
về cái phần quản lý kiến Thế thì em có thể xem được các sản phẩm có sử
dụng thế này đây có thể xóa được cái thể đó coi sản phẩm đó mình có thể thêm thêm
sản phẩm vào cơ thể đồ dùng trang trí ở đây ví dụ gì thêm thì à
Ừ thì nó sẽ với hồ phần này
em có thể đổi tên thể và sau thế Nhưng
mà trước khi xóa thì phải xóa hết tất cả sản phẩm khỏi thì đó
em còn có chức năng rồi ra đây quản lý nhân viên mình có thể xin chưa tiếp
Nhân viên đó là bao nhiêu hóa đơn hình thành cô đơn Để
hôm nay mình yêu lại sau đây đã gửi bao nhiêu số sản phẩm để thêm về sung thêm một cơ thể suy nhược đến sự hoạt động
của nhân viên đó
và phần của con nè phần làm sôi động là Hiển thị ở tất cả lịch sử hoạt động của
nhân viên cho tôi quản lý về
mình có thể xin giá của sản phẩm ở đây có 3 truyền thống kê Ví dụ mình sẽ em sẽ
thống kê theo ví dụ trong tháng 2 này đây nó sẽ hiển thị số sản phẩm bán được
trong tiếng 22 trong ngày gần đây dường như là 14
ngày gần đây à em về ca thống kê hóa đơn
thông tin hội đồng thi trạng thái ứng dụng như là hàng nhập
hệ thống Cao đây trạng thái
về con thống kê thu nhập
rồi thôi bỏ qua mấy vụ thống kê biết thống kê xịn rồi Con còn gì nữa mẹ con
thôi thôi ok Cái thống kê Bạn này đang làm rất hay
có cái khá chi tiết khá nhiều cái nó chiều cao là có một cái cũng
xe hơi giờ tí nhưng mà thôi không sao các bạn cần biết làm này cho biết thôi thực là mấy trang web thường thì nó sẽ
thống kê theo kiểu khác và cũng như là bây rồi ví dụ giả sử em thống kê những cái toàn bộ sản phẩm bán chạy được ạ thì
em đang Liệt kê là không giới hạn số lượng các bạn Nãy giờ đang bị một cái
anh mà Bóc mẽ rồi các bạn dí ngay và toàn bộ mấy cái này các bạn không hề giới hạn số lượng hiển thị ra bây giờ sử
các bạn có 1.000 sản phẩm các bạn không quân trang các bạn không giới hạn gì thì cái biểu đồ lấy trông sẽ như thế nào
chị đã cả câu truy vấn các bạn sẽ chết bởi vì nó rất nặng trả nợ thế thế này là
cái này thì anh anh ghi nhận biết qua tất cả các này thôi chứ ông khoe thêm
nữa rồi bóc mẹ gái ông chết ngay ok còn cái gì nữa không ở đây hết rồi Ok Cảm ơn Cảm ơn hai nhóm
nhé tra tại vẫn đây ở tại mã tắm chẵn này đã
ừ ừ Ừ ok gì à các bạn vừa rồi thấy hai nhóm
Trình bày [âm nhạc] các bạn thấy hay nhóm vừa rồi trình bày
khá ổn Ừ mình cảm thấy cá nhân là rất là ổn so với nhóm bắt đầu
lần đầu tiên trình bày không biết là các bạn như thế nào nếu mà mình nhóm sau thì mình không đi
mình không hi vọng nhiều ngon hơn nhóm này hay bằng nhóm này đâu vịt nhóm Hôm
nay là nhóm tự tính nguyện mà chắc chắn nó họ có tâm lý chuẩn bị cũng như là họ ổn rồi họ mới dám tự nguyện có mấy nhóm
Miễn Cưỡng tình nguyện nhưng mà Ừ nhưng mà mình vẫn chưa làm báo gì Bộ hôm
nay mấy bởi vì à các bạn vẫn còn đang hơi run mình cảm thấy thế nhưng buổi sau
đi dễ có rất nhiều câu hỏi cho các bạn và các bạn sẽ phải quen việc đấy
Anh quay lần việc cả bị người khác nói và mình Nếu mình làm được thì mình sẽ
bảo vệ được bảo vệ đoán chứ có phải là thuyết trình theo kiểu lên vỗ tay lên
thuyết trình xong rồi tất cả mọi người vỗ tay đi xuống không phải như thế bảo vệ đồ án rất là sẽ bị ném cái tơ ta để
một cách kiểu vãi chưởng như thế nào đấy các bạn mà bảo vệ được thì các bạn gọi
là bà phản biện thành công hoặc bảo vệ thành công thế nên là bố hôm nay chưa
gọi bảo vệ gì cả đâu hôm nay chỉ góp ý cũng như là à ăn kẹo để các bạn tự biên tự diễn thôi
chứ chưa có cái gì chấm động đây cả thì các bạn phải vững tâm lý lên nhé bởi
vì tuần sau Nói chung nhà ba ở tuần sau mình sẽ quay ngẫu nhiên Đúng không ngẫu
nhiên chúng nhóm nào kể cả chúng ngon Hôm nay cũng bảo vệ lại này và mình sẽ ném đá một cách kiểu
hết sức cụ thể các bạn phải vay đến các thứ cẩn thận cũng như mình không bắt lỗi
trình mình sẽ không bắt lỗi Hữu trình các bạn nói giun hay gì gì đó mình vẫn sẵn sàng mỗi đội các bạn trình bày hết
nhưng mà mình sẽ bắt lỗi về mặt logic cũng như về xem mà các bạn có thực sự
hiểu các bạn đã làm gì hay không bảo vệ thật thì sẽ vào thứ 7 tuần sau
bảo vệ thật còn thứ ba với từ 5 lần sau sẽ ra bảo vệ chủ tiếc nhưng mà mình sẽ
quay ngẫu nhiên những cái nhóm mà mình duyệt và được bảo vệ lần 1 Huế thì những
nhóm nào mà vàng hôm đấy thì bảo vệ thật mình sẽ không cho đâu nên là nhóm nào
cũng Mỹ Tâm lý từ hôm bắt đầu từ tuần sau đi nếu ngọn sở Lai xong rồi các thứ
phải có hết a word thì à mình
gà mình sẽ chấm dứt sau mình chồng lúc sau hôm bảo vệ thì mình không bỏ tại Bảo
word còn thường các bạn phải in cả cái gốc đấy ra hôm bảo vệ và đưa cho
đưa cho ban hội đồng chấm để ban hội đồng chấm a đọc cái đấy khi mà các bạn
nó thuyết trình để mà biết được thực sự ở các bạn làm những gì nữa nhưng mà bây giờ thì không có rồi đấy à Nếu thế thì
như thế thì hai à bắt đầu từ tuần sau thì mình cũng sẽ yêu
cầu các nhóm phải có worthy để mà lúc mà các bạn vẫn thích trình thì mình sẽ đọc
vuốt các bạn vậy mình phải có cái gì ở đọc mà mình không nhìn mặt các bạn đâu mình cũng thời ra
bạn chọn ý slide lắm rồi sẽ lại mông nặng nhưng Nam tắm chữ thì thường sẽ nhìn vào Word để mà xem
ảnh thực sự các bạn đã làm những gì sơ đồ mạng
anh nói chung hợp tôi sẽ ghi tổng hợp lại những thứ các bạn cần chuẩn bị từ
bắt đầu làm sao Các bạn thấy có vẻ là hôm nay xong thì các bạn thấy á hình
dung hơn về cái đồ án này chưa ạ Thấy nó cũng cũng ghê gớm nhưng mà khi mà bảo bảo vệ
xong thì các bạn thấy nó có thỏa mãn thỏa mãn không ạ Thấy kiểu dạng mà mình
trưởng thành hơn không thế nên là đồ ăn một rõ như này rồi đón hai con còn kinh
khủng hơn còn cái khủng đó nữa gì để mà sao cho các bạn xong cái đồ ăn
Hải các bạn hãy đi làm rồi Các bạn sợ là chẳng sợ bố con nào đang sợ bất kỳ đứa ở phỏng vấn đề các bạn thoải mái
Ừ lúc đấy các bạn hoàn toàn thể kẹo 300 sợ cả người vào làm trước mình luôn
về lúc đầy các bạn khẳng định là các bạn vừa có kiến thức và vừa biết cách chứ
chỉnh biết phản biện các thứ thứ nên chẳng phải lo gì cả cho tôi vẫn khẳng định nhé đó là khóa
các bạn làm kết thúc được khóa này và khóa sau nữa làm được cái đồ án chỉ cần bảo vệ mà tôi vượt qua là các bạn đi làm
được rồi Lương có thể nổ đến 78 triệu Vẫn được không bỏ qua là vụ thực tập
luôn thì các bạn muốn thế không ạ Thế nên thế nếu mà muốn thế thì chắc cả các bạn phải
nghiêm túc vào trong cái đồ này đúng không ạ học thực tế có thể dự
chú ý bạn kia chắc là hỏi là bao giờ có một khóa bảo đùa đoán web cơ bản mới đúng không
Thực ra là mình hiện tại thì mình cũng chưa có ý định là sẽ dạy lại cài khóa cơ
bản này tạm thừa như thế phía sau nếu mà đông bạn yêu cầu quá thì mình sẽ dậy sau
Nhưng mà chắc phải về sau thì cả mấy hạn Nói chung là lâu lắm đấy là các bạn bây
giờ nên xem lại từ buổi một thôi có ngờ tạm hết đột để bảo vệ đồ án đất mua rồi
ở đợt 2 vẫn hay người làm thôi vẫn là hai người là ba người đó rất là vấn đề
hai người đã có nhiều vấn đề được
à à Ừ ok cho buổi hôm nay thấy đâu nhỉ các bạn ấy Tôi tin là nhiều ông có nhiều cảm
xúc Kiểu hồi hộp và cũng run nhiều lắm Tôi cũng thế thôi tôi hồi hộp mà
thì các bạn cũng thắc mắc gì thì cho là mình tạm cái gốc đây nhá chào các bạn
nhé ừ ừ